I got it the Trader Joe's instant Boba
kit I've gotten a lot of DMS telling me
to try this to review this so here it is
the brown sugars tapioca pearl drink mix
let's give it a try the packaging is
very pretty comes with straws paper
straws and it has four packs I'm gonna
do the microwave method we're just gonna
pop this in for 60 seconds
so I'm gonna add my Boba ice
and the directions say to just add milk
but my Boba experience is not complete
without the tea so I made some tea you
don't need the sweetener because it was
already in the packet and last but not
least our milk I hope that's really
pretty a little mix give it a try
you know I really like that it's Tapioca
And it's not the imposters you know like
agar popping Boba konjac Mochi the Boba
is on the smaller side than what we're
used to getting in America but I will
say when I went back to Taiwan the size
was very similar to this size a little
smaller nice and QQ very bouncy very
good and I like the brown sugar flavor
it's nice and Rich and uh I approve